يسعى
لتحويل الجيش الصيني الى جيش فولاذي
ولتنفيذ هذه الخطه رفعت بكين من ميزانيه
الدفاع بنسبه
7.2% خلال العام الجاري
مليار دولار لكن لا فائده من تطوير وشراء
الاسلحه من دون اداره الجيش ابي الطريقه
الامثل وزير دفاعا جديد كما ذكرنا مع وجود
لجنه مركزيه عسكريه ستكون مسؤوليتها
الاشراف على كل ما يتعلق بالجيش بافرعه
المختلفه بما يضمن امن الصين القومي على
مدار عقد حكمته البلاد لم يعين رئيس
اللجنه وهو تشي نفسه لم يعين نائبا اول له
من خلفيه مدنيه هذا المنصب تولاه هو نفسه
عام 2010 قبل ان يتراس اللجنه في عام 2012
اي قبل توليه الرئاسه بعدها بعام من بين
مهام اللجنه طبعا قضيه تايوان بكين صبرها
ينفد كما تعيين وايدونج القائد السابق
للجبهه الشرقيه المواجهه لتايوان نائبا
لرئيس اللجنه سابقه اولى من نوعها في هذا
التعيين الرجل ليس لديه عضويه اي من لجنتي
الحزب سواء العسكريه او المركزيه اذا خطط
الصين كثيره ومنها ما هو في بحر الصين
الجنوبي تمر منه معظم تجاره الصين ولذلك
تعمل بكين بخطه اخرى على زياده نفوذها
وقوتها فيه لكن كيف عبر خطه طويله الامد
بدات منذ نحو عقد وقت تولي شي الرئاسه عبر
سفنونها الجارفه للرمال حولت الصين الشعاب
المرجانيه الى جزر اصطناعيات تستخدم
كمواقع عسكريه خطه صينيه شملت ايضا بناء
مواقع قتاليه متقدمه
على القوات الامريكيه فثلاثه من تلك
المواقع توجد في جزر اسبارتلي التي شهدت
مؤخرا اكثر من حادث بين الجنوبين وكذلك
مواقع في جزر بارسيل اقصى الشمال ومن اجل
ذلك للحفاظ على خطوطها اللوجستيه مفتوحه
مع قواعدها الجزريه النائيه في جزر مارسيل
وجزر سباركلي طورت بكين التنين اكبر طائره
برمائيه في العالم تقلع وتهبط على المدارج
البريه مثل اي طائره تقليديه او تنطلق
بسلاسه من على المسطحات المائيه بفضل
العوامات المتدليه تحت اجنحتها
[موسيقى]